you'll die why are you doing this why
[Music]
oh dude seriously you gotta clean up
your room it's a complete mess
I'm good I'm not boring you're boring
you know what's boring sitting there
playing that mind-numbing game what's
boring is me tripping over your vines
every day I'm not boring now I know how
y'all new felt the hell are you guys
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie I'm getting a
lot of questions about baby Groot Groot
adolescent Groot infinity war Groot
so James Gunn has been answering a lot
of people's questions he's really good
about interacting with the fans and
clarifying certain story beats because
there been a lot of character changes
from the comics so I just wanted to
explain what all he had said and what it
means for infinity war we know a little
bit about how Groot is gonna be used
during infinity war because of the
scenes they've included in the trailer
in what we know what's going on with
Thor's character so right now adolescent
Groot is most important to Thor's
character but he's one of the most
popular characters in the guardians of
the galaxy of course he's gonna be doing
a bunch of stuff during the movie so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway is
still going on so starting with James
Gunn's first comments you know first big
thing here and this is a big change from
the comics he says first Groot is dead
baby Groot is his son and when he says
son he's talking about grown from a
sport because he's a plant so plants
have spores he was grown from that they
stuck them in a plant that's how you get
to dancing baby Groot that's how they
got to baby Groot in the second film
[Music]
when we got to the second film there was
a really short amount of time that
passed between films so that's why baby
Groot is still very much a baby but big
enough so that he could be a part of the
film and not just be a potted plant
sitting on a shelf somewhere so James
Gunn goes on he has a couple funny
replies to people where someone is upset
about
JK Rowling walking back things like a
long time ago JK Rowling answered a
bunch of questions about the Harry
Potter universe she clarified some
really controversial aspects of the
characters that didn't make it into the
books for fear of censorship so when the
new films came out she rolled back some
of the things that she had said so fans
are really upset James Gunn's reply is
totally hilarious I mean he's just
saying that they're not gonna walk that
back if it made it into the movie then
it's canon as hell that's the most
canonized that something could be within
the MCU because everything is dictated
by what happens in the movies they've
even changed the colors of the infinity
gems in the comics to match the colors
that they are in the movies if you've
ever wondered how groots race reproduces
he also explains that to asexually so
it's not like he had to get help from
another member of his race so then he
goes on to say this is probably the more
important part that baby Groot doesn't
have any of the memories from adult
Groot which is another big comic book
change so if you haven't read the comics
you've actually seen how Groot can just
like break pieces of himself off he'll
grow them back he's a plant he's
continually growing just like humans
grow skin cells he grows plant cells so
that's why his vines are hilariously
strewn all over his room they have that
funny post credit scene he pointed out
very emphatically that he's adolescent
group during infinity war not teenage
Groot so that just means he's like 11 to
13 years old if he were teenage Groot
he'd be more like Peter Parker age he
said not to get too messed up with the
timeline just because they don't grow in
mature at the same rate that humans do
so it could take him a lot longer it
could take him a little while the comic
book explainer even though they've
changed the comics is that they can grow
as fast as they want
so if adolescent Groot wanted to become
adult Groot all he would have to do is
just sort of think it and will himself
to grow and he would do that but one of
the biggest changes that they made from
the comics is that his race is able to
regrow itself from
single piece of their own biomatter so
think like Lobo over in the DC Universe
he can regrow his entire body Wolverine
style from a single drop of blood so all
you need for Groot in the comics is like
a splinter or a leaf or just like some
little piece of him stick him in a plant
give him water boom group grows back to
full size he still has all the same
memories it's still the same version
he's talked about how he hates the fact
that in comics and movies and TV shows
characters are brought back to life all
the time people die then they're brought
right back there's no weight to the
story at all so adult Groot sacrificing
himself during the first movie had to
stick which is also why I think they
haven't brought Coulson back into the
movie universe that's also why I think
the baby Groot doesn't have adult roots
memories because one they want to have
some of those funny moments like the
press the button scene he was like Groot
would know which button to push if it
were adult Groot in tiny groots body
[Music]
so again I think giving him that
different personality is just to
simplify the logic of the character so
that he looks like a baby but he also
acts like a baby because he is a baby
then as you see him in all these funny
scenes in the infinity war trailer
adolescent GRU could care less about all
this infinity war Thanos business and
he's just gonna play his video games for
those of you asking about what's gonna
happen to him during infinity war in
Avengers 4 I don't think he's gonna grow
that much bigger I think he'll stay
relatively the same size the same age
because the films are back to back so
Avengers 4 picks up in the moments after
Avengers 3 in depending on how big they
want the time jump to be for Avengers 4
- guardians 3 he'll either be a little
bit bigger like he'll be teenaged Groot
or he will finally grow to full size
adult Groot by the end of that film
because that's supposed to be the final
ride for this roster of guardians what
I'm really hoping at the end of
guardians 3 is that they cycle out just
a couple of the characters but Rocket
Groot and at least star-lord stick
around and they put Adam warlock on the
team so it becomes the Adam warlock
version of guardians of the galaxy in
whatever fourth film they do because I
know everybody's wondering about actors
leaving their contracts ending Chris
Pratt has said on numerous occasions
that he's gonna continue to recycle and
be in new Marvel movies until they
forcibly throw him off the lot and tell
him he's not allowed to be in Marvel
stuff anymore so I don't think you got
to worry about star-lord dying anytime
soon but as for like Drax or Gamora or
nebula you know it just depends on which
guardians actors want to stick around
but definitely at least one or two of
these members will not be around after
guardians 3 so a big question let me
know in the comments do you think that
we'll see full-sized adult Groot
during guardians 3 in which guardians do
you think will either die or leave the
team after guardians 3 there's a bunch
more Marvel stuff coming next week but
the Oscars are happening tonight if
there's any big comic book stuff that
happens I'll totally do a video for it
spider-man and black panther are
presenting an award but otherwise
there's not a whole lot of comic book
stuff happening effects artists working
in concert with virtually every
department apply their expertise to
serve the story and to make the audience
believe that even an ordinary man can
climb walls spin webs and swing through
the air so leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below on AIM
new winner for that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway when I post new Marvel click
here for my brand new iron spider reveal
video and click here for that infinity
war promo thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]